7h15 avec du matin comment commencer ses
journées à paris pour être en forme et
ce surtout se maintenir en forme
piscine nager alors y'en a qui vont
courir ferme trempé lyon
[Musique]
c'est d'ailleurs le ghana qui monte aux
réformes sort
aujourd'hui on va faire une faq
je réponds à toutes les questions mais
posez combat en commentaire les premiers
marchés aux premiers rendez-vous du
matin prendre des formes jus d'orange là
et qu'un peu lumière ça va mieux je sais
qu'aujourd'hui je vais vous emmener avec
moi j'ai pas mal de différents
rendez-vous comme ça vous allez partager
ma journée tout au long de la journée ça
va être quand même plutôt sympa alors on
commence ce matin à 10 heures au salon
de la photo porte de versailles
c'est à une heure de métro d'ici donc ya
pas falloir trop tarder il va être 9
heures concours se magne un petit peu
ensuite j'ai un défi pour le boulot à
12h30 à 16h j'ai un petit casse-croûte
un petit 4 heures avec au nord pour
aller récupérer un dernier smartphone le
aux normes fixe et puis ensuite ce soir
soirée samsung explorer
[Musique]
lâche un petit tour sur le stand de
nikon présenter le nouveau médecin quand
on est sur un boîtier semi pros amateurs
un peu des deux c'est vraiment le cas
pareil le portel shoot vous prenez c'est
vachement cool c'est pas pour tout le
monde mais en fait si vous voulez débuté
dans la photo en appareils secondaire
s'intéresse tout ce qui est pas mal
c'est ça la
au nez vous tendez
vous pouvez vous prononcez le fille
alors pour moi c'est pas 3d parce que
c'est un bad boy apple mais son principe
c'est le cas du passage express au salon
de la photo
les flics sont assez intéressants en
fait en j'ai fait les grandes marques
j'ai paniqué tout voir je pense qu'il ya
plein de choses vraiment vraiment
vraiment il tracoulat les voies savons
la photo qui est plutôt bien du 7au
entre donc novembre si vous avez
l'occasion si vous aimez la photo et la
vidéo
il ya plein de petites pépites de retour
au studio c'est l'heure de la faq vous
emmène je vais partager plein de choses
voyez comme ça s'en vient avec moi dans
les événements on va continuer mais pour
l'instant on fait une petite pause faq
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreuses et
plus en plus nombreux à me poser toutes
vos questions faq c'est vachement bien
parce que ça veut dire que vous avez des
besoins de réponse qu'il ait plus de 600
commentaires sur la faq là j'ai
sélectionné 112 question il y en a
beaucoup dont on va aller très vite et
j'ai essayé de vous répondre à tous le
plus rapidement possible dans les
meilleures conditions que la meilleure
information
alors on commence qu'elle est
l'innovation que tu aimerais voir le
plus dans les smartphones iphone ou
android
en fait je sais pas s'il ya une
meilleure innovation c'est pour moi
quelque chose qui me surprendrait pas ce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de smartphones qui se
ressemblent en rien des innovations
meilleure caméra meilhan écran les
grands écrans on va voir les caméras
sous l'écran est mal de choses comme ça
qui sont très intéressantes
je sais pas je profite d'un petit peu
différent une proposition un peu
différente le coût des smartphones
pliable pour moi c'est vraiment
différent pour coup et c'est très
intéressant
pourquoi ne fait-il pas tes vidéos au
format 18 9e au lieu du format 16 9ème
art format 16/9 cependant un petit peu
plus standard c'est plus le format
ordinateur je sais que beaucoup cela te
format 18 9e
néanmoins lorsque vous regardez sur une
télé le format 18 9e marche - parce que
c'est beaucoup plus allongée sur un ordi
ça me dérange pas c'est vrai que ça
dépend du format de smartphones si vous
avez des smartphones 18/9 c'est bien
cette nouvelle mais finir krupp et si
vous avez un format 21/9 là il faut
venir carrément krupp et ça ne mange du
contenu raw et en bas j'ai pas trouvé
encore la recette idéale je suis pas
forcément convaincu par le 18 9e
peut-être que j'y reviendrai je sais pas
avoir ce que tu feras un jour des vidéos
sur des skates bornes électriques je
suis pas sûr peut-être si l'opportunité
se présente quel premier téléphone que
tu donc je me demande si c'est pas un
33-10 de nokia je vous
les crocs ce col sont ils totalement
français que penses tu de nouveaux
produits à leurs proches colle pour
montre là c'est une marque française qui
est basée à aix en provence je crois pas
qu'ils le capital étranger intérieur ça
vraiment beaucoup de prudence parce que
je ne sais pas mais pour moi c'est
vraiment une boîte française de
téléphonie française leur dernier
smartphone en date c'est le traiteur
excitant qui était présenté l année
dernière que je trouve très intéressante
pour l'outdoor pour tous un métier vous
avez besoin d'un smartphone résistants
qui va pas se casser pour moi c'est très
cool j'aime beaucoup leur proposition au
niveau de la caméra qui fait actions
comme source un très bon coup est ce qu
un essuie-tout je suis plus valent le
coup en 2019 2020 le et suite comment ça
un petit peu à vieillir par rapport à ce
qu'on peut avoir avec le s9 néanmoins il
reste quand même d'actualité
je pense que si tu trouves un et suite à
internet qui est vraiment très
intéressant ça beaucoup tu peux y ait
quelqu'un peut me dire si c'est bien de
samsung galaxy bugs à cette fin d'année
bancaire est ce que les samsung galaxy
de beule sont intéressants fin 2019 oui
clairement voit très bien
samsung galaxy watch active 2 ou apple
watch series 5
en fait c'est pas une question de
produits c'est une question
d'écosystèmes c'est une question dos
dans quel os est ce que tu es est-ce que
c'est l'écosystème apple
auquel cas il faut que tu aies ça il
faut que tu es un iphone pour la faire
fonctionner sinon ça ne sert strictement
rien une samsung galaxy watch actif deux
tu peux la faire fonctionner sur ios
si tu as un iphone tu vas sur la watch
de apple qui marche très bien et si tu
es android tu vas sur la samsung galaxy
watch active 2 je possède actuellement
on voit de plus c'est trop j'ai failli
craquer pour le mclaren mais trop proche
de mon roi de plus actuel je donc savoir
s'il aura un web plus 8 mclaren edition
je ne sais absolument pas il y aura un
owen +8 ça ça me paraît être une
évidence un one + 8 mclaren et shon
probablement mais ça c'est à voir si
effectivement ou une puce reconduit son
partenariat avec mclaren l'année
prochaine probablement qu'une constitue
entre une samsung galaxy watch 46 mm et
la watch active de la web s'activent de
l est quand même vachement cool j'ai un
samsung à 40 tu me conseilles quoi entre
les samsung galaxy boys et r paul ce
projet pas encore sortis de la vie des
hôtesses d'air paul-froment on en parle
très très très prochainement mais avec
thor ça me saoule à 40 conseils les
galaxies bugs est-ce que youtube est ton
seul métier nerfs j'ai fait une petite
rugby âgées bien j'adore dessus mon se
disant est ce que youtube est mon seul
guide will you tube et mon seul métier à
100 % du lundi au dimanche je travaille
tous les jours oui full time job
à fond en france que pensez-vous de la
marque motorola vaut-elle le coup
d'investir motorola souffre loïc et mon
avis depuis quelques années là on
pouvait retrouver sur l'entrée milieu de
gamme c'est pas forcément la marque sous
laquelle moi j'irai directement
ils ont néanmoins des propositions de
valeur qui sont intéressantes il essaye
des choses c'est pas encore à mon avis
suffisamment sexy par rapport à des
acteurs comme xiaomi qui raflent quand
même beaucoup dans l'entrée de gamme
entre et milieu de gamme
j'aime beaucoup de vidéos j'aimerais
acheter un smartphone avec un budget de
600 euros cherche à son smartphone bon
autonomie en performance
après pas mal de recherches je pense que
le moine plus c'est télé shiomi 1009
décembre et l'adapter à mes attentes
mais le problème est de savoir lequel
prendre que tu m'aider oui je peux aider
je te conseille le one plus cet été ne
serait-ce que pour l'écran 90 ans moi
j'adore quand tu montes chambre d'hôtel
je t'invite en côte d'ivoire merci
hubert où il en parle dans la présente
est facussé savoir si vous aimez que tu
as un peu vous loguez quand je vous
montre un peu les chambres d'hôtels dans
lesquels je suis est-ce que tu
accepterais de venir en côte d'ivoire
j'aimerais beaucoup revenir en côte
d'ivoire je suis jamais venu en côte
d'ivoire mais un jour pourquoi pas quel
avis as-tu vis-à-vis du d'ascq redevient
un sujet de discussion à cordes dernière
étude dessus le d'asthme données très
importantes quant aux ondes
on va recevoir lorsqu'on à son
smartphone à l'oreille ou dans la poche
je pense qu'il faut quand même faire
gaffe lorsque vous téléphonez mieux vaut
utiliser un petit casque filaire pour
éviter d'avoir tout le temps le
smartphone à l'oreille essayer de se
protéger là dessus mais lorsque vous
utilisez pas votre smartphone éviter de
la voir tout le temps contre vous garder
loin pas distance
je dirais que c'est un principe de
précaution il ya des ondes elles sont là
quels sont les effets maintenant à moyen
et long terme c'est un peu compliqué
d'avoir un recul là dessus mais dans
tous les cas il ya des jours je pense
qu'il faut quand même prendre ce sujet
très au sérieux
j'espère qu'il va bien gérer ce que tu
fais j'aimerais savoir iphone onze
classique ou 10 s max merci davance
alors au niveau du processeur l'iphone
11 sera plus performant que le dissès
max par an au niveau de l'écran je te
rends tu es quand même d'aller sur le
dissès max tu as une meilleure
résolution et franchement la différence
de performances ça se joue à pas grand
chose
monsieur breux are you gouic geek i'm
not agree geek
à quand le test du xperia 5 très bientôt
il est là le xperia 5 pour cela tu as
très bientôt on en parle très très très
prochainement bonjour monsieur re tu
utilises quel portable actuellement
j'utilise en ce moment le pixel 4 de
google plutôt bien mais je souffre un
peu de
en tout cas plutôt bien est-ce que tu
gagnes assez avec youtube pour ne pas
travailler mais je travaille sache que
youtube c'est beaucoup de travail c'est
à peu près 10 à 12 heures de travail par
jour et 3 5 heures le week-end y compris
dimanche non que oui aujourd'hui je vis
que de youtube mais pour ne pas
travailler à côté
j'entends bien j'entends bien ça comme
ça oui aujourd'hui je ne fais que ça que
ça prend beaucoup de temps c'est quoi ta
marque préférée ton tel préféré j'ai pas
de marques préférées
j'apprécie beaucoup de marques de par
les innovations de par ce qu'ils tendent
à proposer sauf qu'à des marques qui
innove qui essaye des choses j'ai pas de
marque fétiche
il ya des marques que j'aime bien avec
lesquels j'ai une histoire quand j'étais
un peu plus jeune
il ya des trucs que mais pas dire que
c'est vraiment de marque préférée
question du canada salue au canada les
revues du pixel quatre sont mitigés est
ce que le pixel 4xl est ok niveau
batterie écoute je n'ai pas testé le
pixel 4xl maintenant j'aimerais faire
par rapport à ce que je dis là une année
entre pixels 3 et 17 3 xl
le pixel 3xl avait une plus grosse
batterie était meilleur en autonomie
elle est aussi un écran un peu plus
grand que consommer davantage
mais pouvait un peu plus loin en tout
cas le retour j'ai sur pixels 4
c'est que si je tiens une journée c'est
que je n'utilise pas énormément je peux
dès fois tenir une journée mais pas tout
le temps là je suis à 67% patrie mais je
les recharger pendant une heure tout à
l'heure donc bon voilà c'est voilà sinon
moins de +7 et pro ou pixels 4 je dirais
que si tu veux bien un smartphone qui
tient plus d'une journée le one plus si
c'est la question d'autonomie en tout
cas qu'est ce qui t'a déranger chez le
galaxy fold pour être rectifiées que son
successeur l'encoche à l'intérieur je
suis pas it right right rafan le petit
écran de notification peut être un peu
agrandie où on peut lui trouver des
usages différents pense qu'un truc à
trouver un peu du coup peut-être du côté
de l'ouest là dessus pour le rendre un
peu plus sexy sur veut garder un petit
format comme ça combien de téléphones
est ce que tu as
tellement je voudrais savoir s'ils
portaient des casques bluetooth et
nocifs pour la santé
il y à des ombres des ondes plus courte
je suis pas un spécialiste des ombres
que je vais pas vous raconter n'importe
quoi est ce que c'est nocif pour la
santé aujourd'hui je suis pas persuadé
après est ce que ce n'est pas nocif pour
la santé
je suis pas non plus personnellement ce
qu'il faudrait regarder du côté des
études s'il ya des choses là dessus et
une fois de plus c'est compliqué d'avoir
un retour à moyen et long terme ce qu'on
peut voir c'est un peu à court terme
est-ce qu'à long terme c'est viable ou
pas l'avenir nous le dira y aura-t-il la
note 11 et 11 plus c'est une bonne
question alors si on suit la logique de
samsung depuis des années oui on se
dirait qu'il va y avoir un autre 11 et
notons plus maintenant est-ce que ça de
gamme note 17 garde vraiment son intérêt
au delà du style et ils sont quand même
très similaire de ce qu'on peut
retrouver avec les galaxy s 10 et s 10 +
9 10 no 10 plus je pense tu auras encore
un autre 11 l'année prochaine je pense
qu'il faut qu'il soit différent du onze
après ceux liés par une harmonisation au
niveau cette gamme
c'est pas impossible je sais pas encore
à voir est ce que le au port et no2 vaut
le coup aux prix actuels ou est ce qu'il
vaut mieux attendre qu'il baisse un peu
ou alors se dirigeait plutôt vers un
concurrent a tant le black friday
je pense faire des choses intéressantes
à ce moment là tu me conseilles qu entre
le one + 71 et le one + 7 tpr aux
mclaren le meilleur rapport qualité-prix
s'éloigne plus cette équipe très bon
style maintenant tu veux 12 il ya drame
et si tu veux le design may cry que tu
vas payer cher tu payes soins de plus
cet epr aux mclaren mais pour moi le
flagship qui leur amènent c'est le web
depuis cet été quels événements tech est
meilleur le mobile world congress qui a
lieu fin février et bien parce qu'il est
vraiment smartphones et que moi je parle
beaucoup de moi donc ça m'intéresse mais
le quota peut plus se voit de fuck au
niveau des nouvelles technologies ça
reste quand même le csa veille as tu
penses que le s rose aura un autre un
trou dans l'écran ou que la caméra sera
sous l'écran je pense lilian que la
caméra sera sous l'écran pour le s 11 ça
me paraît être l'innovation qu'il faut
en tout cas samsung début 2010 main
sinon je vois pas trop quelles
innovations il va avoir encore plus de
performances une meilleure autonomie
un meilleur appareil photo bon le truc
il serait vraiment what the fuck qui
ferait qu' elles sont serait vraiment
intéressant c'est vraiment la caméra
sous l'écran et l'aurait liens des
projets
vidéo en commun avec d'autres youtuber
salut stéphane pas prévu pour le moment
parce qu'en fait je me dis que si je
veux faire un projet avec deux tubes
heures il faut que les instances avec
probablement une série vidéo qui
s'inscrivent dans le temps donc je
réfléchis mais c'est pas encore trouvé
une idée d'ailleurs si vous avez une
idée pour bien marquer en bas en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous voudriez
comme collab avec l'aide de tubes pour y
aller pas forcément tel qu'on peut
parler de pas d'univers différents ça
peut être intéressant
à partir de quel âge peut-on avoir un
ordi il ya les ordi pour tous les haltes
si vous regardez ce que font des
constructeurs de jouer vous avez des
ordi pour les enfants pour commencer à
comprendre
maintenant la question c'est à quel âge
peut-on mettre un ordi d'un ordi style
baba ce style ce genre de choses entre
les mains d'un enfant ou pas c'est la
même question la voici à quel âge
peut-on mettre un smartphone dans les
mains de l'enfant à creuser tout ça tu
va tester leur aide mint huit pros oui
d'ailleurs je me tâtais affaire a fait
une vidéo red minott huit pros raid
minot twitté comparatif lequel acheter
je pense que ça peut avoir un temps
c'est sa taille il est pas mal de monde
et un rythme aussi à vous intéresse que
je le fasse comme ça rémy n'a qu'une
promesse réduit de tweets et c'est quoi
ta couleur préférée pour un smartphone
pas réellement de couleur préférée
j'aime bien rouge voilà tu préfères
envoi ne plus toucher au but et j'aime
bien les deux les deux pour les deux
marques sont vraiment différentes
one + sort très peu de smartphones elle
si on a eu un peu plus cette année et
cette fois propose des propositions qui
sont vraiment très pointue très
pertinent très intéressante
ça c'est vraiment cool shiomi vous allez
beaucoup de produits vous avez un très
gros et costumes sont des marques sont
vraiment différents qui travaillent
vraiment différemment donc c'est
compliqué d'avoir une préférence au
travail de salut je voudrais savoir si
tu conseilles les écouteurs à vibrations
osseuse
florian c'est rigolo mais c'est pas là
que tu vas voir la meilleure qualité
comme ce gros comptes tu faire un forum
louis estelle c'est en cours comme
beaucoup de projets qui sont en cours ça
va arriver très très très très
prochainement faq samsung galaxy s 10e
ou à 50 personnellement j'ai acheté le
a50 je ne sais pas trop qui le meilleur
clairement le meilleur ce ls 10 e
néanmoins le a50 marche bien on n'est
pas sur la même gamme de produits je
préférais en tout cas le édition j'ai
envoyé des vins light et j'hésite à
m'acheter un honneur d'y slight penses
tu que ça vaut le coup de changer non
parce que le père marek est très récent
il y appelle de l'année dernière alors
effectivement il ya quelques mois on
peut dire qu'il ya un peu plus d'un an
je pense que si ton smartphone marche
encore et qu'il te convient bien
je pense pas que ça vaille le coup de
changer pour l'instant attend peut-être
l'année prochaine
quelle est la différence entre le neuf
et reconditionnés et donc me conseilles
tu d'acheter du reconditionnés la
différence en fait c'est que le 9 nov
jusque là je pense que je t'apprends
plus rien le reconditionner ya deux
types de reconditionner tu vas voir le
reconditionner ou les personnes ont pris
leur smartphone et ensuite soit des
ordinateurs
qu'ils ont renvoyée sous 14 jours donc
on a dû reconditionnés mais un produit
qui en fait n'a pas beaucoup vécu et on
a dû reconditionnés de produits qui a
vécu un an un an et demi et qui à ce
moment là potentiellement aura une durée
de vie un peu moins longue que ce qu'on
pourrait avoir si on avait un smartphone
néanmoins ça permet d'acheter un
smartphone beaucoup moins cher ça permet
d'avoir des produits qui dure plus dans
le temps il faut savoir quand même que
si vous achetez un produit
reconditionnés par une boutique qui est
sérieuse si toutefois la batterie ne
marche pas et bien on vous l'a changée
si la sauce ils ont beau changer si
l'écran est un petit peu endommagé ils
vont vous changez donc normalement vous
êtes tranquille puis vous avez surtout
des garanties derrière tu me conseilles
quoi entre l'iphone 8 et le moins de
plus cette promo moi je te conseillerai
le one + 7 prouve qu'elle est meilleure
en trouver samsung sds plus ça me saoule
note 10 plus folles photos vidéos les
images sont des cinq vidéos
sinon le meilleur portable en fait si
pour la partie photo s10 plus note 10
plus fold c'est quasiment la même chose
près images ça va dépendre si tu me
parles de photos si tu me parles d'écran
là c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
mais si la question se dirigent juste
sur la partie photo vidéo moi c'est kif
kif bourricot
est-ce que tu as prévu de faire de
nouveau trip comme ce que tu as fait
avec roscoff c'était vraiment excellent
c'était vraiment cool ce qu'on à faire
des crocs ce col c'est très atypique
parce qu'en fait le cros colle à une
proportion de valeurs qui est vraiment
très atypique c'est du smartphone
outdoor ils m'ont emmené dans leur
univers j'ai adoré ça c'est un peu
l'idée en fait qu'ils voulaient quand je
vous emmène quand j'ai quelque chose
d'un peu plus vous loguez on est dans
cette idée là je me rentrer dans
l'univers de la marque
j'aimerais bien faire un truc avec
roscoat parce que je trouve ça vraiment
cool je me posais la question comment ça
marche et partenariats alors en fait à
différents types de partenariats j'ai
travaillé avec des marques mois des
smartphones comme typiquement ici là
celui acquis xperia 5 est bien géré un
partenariat où je vais parler de leurs
produits dit juste que je veux c'est de
ma ligne éditoriale je vais tester le
produit je leur envoie il repart et
après vous avez des partenariats qu'on
n'a pas les partenariats régulière est
la fameuse vidéo sponso auquel cas on
m'envoie un produit je le teste
je dis ce que j'ai à dire mais je suis
payé pour simple la différence se situe
à près du point de vue moi de ma ligne
éditoriale si j'ai quelque chose à dire
si le produit ne me plaît pas même si
c'est sponsorisés je vous le dirai pas
ce que si ça va pas ça va pas et même si
c'est payé je vous le dirai de la même
manière maintenant par contre la seule
différence c'est que j'aurai un retour
avec la marque je redirai on a moins
côté voilà ça j'ai trouvé que ça
n'allait pas ça ça va bien je devrais
regarder la vidéo avant mais de toute
façon je veux pas supprimer la partie
qui ne va pas sous prétexte que c'est
payé à ce moment là on préfère refuser
que de le faire voilà un peu comment ça
marche tu as eu différentes îles de
partenariat
bonjour j'hésite entre les erp aux pros
et les erp hodge deuxième génération
boîtier sans charge le cas il me
conseille qu on parle très prochainement
derrière paul ce pro comme ça tu sauras
tout le monde vante pro et qui encore un
bon choix de smartphones oui je connais
encore plein de journalistes qui
l'utilisé qui marche très très bien pour
ce truc à l'évolution de l'informatique
quantique or un jour un impact sur
l'informatique embarquée smartphone
smartwatch oui eric mais dans l'autre
j'ai aussi une question si tu pouvais y
répondre le pixel malgré son appareil
photo ce téléphone est un échec en fait
le pixel c'est pas que ça n'ait c'est
que google ne vend pas beaucoup de
pixels c'est pas le smartphone qui va
être le plus vendu par contre un tour de
force c'est une vitrine pour
l'écosystème de google ce soit au niveau
de la photo que ce soit au niveau même
d'android on peut vraiment voir tourner
cet androïde complètement optimisé
google mail à google pour google
s'inscrit dans un écosystème google
comment un smartphone en 2020 pourra
déclencher un effet au wahoo l'effet
waouh on pourrait en avoir sur les
smartphones très audacieux et très
différents non je pense notamment qu'on
peut avoir un effet whaou au niveau des
caméras planquées sous l'écran ça peut
être vraiment très intéressante des
propositions de valeur au niveau du
smartphone pliable je pense qu'en 2020
il se peut qu'elles étaient trois ou là
dessus que penses tu des surfaces du
oeneo le duo est il un smartphone et
l'entre-deux d'une tablette et le
smartphone moi je les ai vus lors de
leur lancement à new york j'ai pas pu
les prendre en main la proposition est
intéressante je me suis dit mais
pourquoi nous avons mis un écran pliable
c'est un peu dommage alors après pont
côté tablette ou implique tous les côtés
ça marcherait pas avec un écran pliable
donc je pense que c'est pour ça que
maintenant il faut vraiment faire usage
donc il faut que je puisse l'avoir entre
les mains l'utiliser me rendre compte de
l' usage sur le principe
pourquoi pas mais sans l'avoir entre les
mains julien c'est compliqué de donner
la vraie bonne réponse joe jalousie à y
collectionne ziyaye jol collection à la
fois en studio et sur le terrain est ce
que tu es le frileux est ce que tu es le
fils de fred et jamy c'est pas possible
tu prévu de retourner cette année au
hellfest oui kevin j'ai ma place pour le
fais je serai au hellfest en 2020
faut-il acheter un téléphone haut de
gamme qui est sorti il ya deux trois ans
ou un téléphone à moins de 250 euros qui
est sorti cette année
moi je pense quand même un smartphone
deux ans on a des trucs qui sont
vraiment bien par rapport à les
smartphones qui sont sortis cette année
après les propositions de valeur qui
sont quand même vraiment cool à 12,50
euros notamment regardez là j'ai
récupéré gelé dans la poche et le au
nord de fix celui-là il vraiment cool ce
qui est vraiment intéressant pour le
prix en fait c'est que vous avez
absolument aucune en poche vous avez une
petite caméra pop up à 250 euros
ça c'est vraiment cool après j'ai un
écran lcd j'ai pas dû aux led si par
contre fait sur du haut de gamme dit à
deux ans je vais avoir du haut l'aide
sera pas exactement la même chose ça
dépend ce qu'on veut ça dépend ce qu'on
veut privilégier mais pour moi ça vaut
le coup de se positionner sur un
smartphone haut de gamme via de 3,15
smartphone tu peux me conseiller pour un
budget de 400 à 600 euros ps je joue au
je regarde des vidéos youtube et je ne
sors pas une réseaux sociaux ce sera mon
premier smartphone huawei sa pole c'est
le truc auquel il faut pas se planter
parce que la première fois quelle
qu'elle soit c'est un truc qui marque et
même avec un smartphone et j'aime
surtout avec un smartphone parce que tu
passe beaucoup de temps avec ton
smartphone budget 400 à 600 euros
si tu arrives à être vraiment prêt du
budget des 600 euros pour moi tout qui
serait vraiment cool pourquoi paul je
dirais c'est le one + 71 parce que il
combine plein de bonnes choses et de
pouvoir regarder quand même suffisamment
l'autre genf en 10 s max et l'apple
watch 4 est ce que ça vaut le coup de
changer pour l'iphone 11 promax et
l'apple watch cinq noms anthony garder
ça sert à rien et des produits sont très
récents ils sont à peine de l'année
dernière en plus entre la ouache 4 et
lounge 5
il n'y a pas un écart qui est énorme
entre le dissès max et le 11 promax il
n'y a pas non plus un écart qui est
l'enjeu du conseil de guerre d'été
produits je pense que ça vaut pas le
coup de changer tous les ans ça coûte
très cher c'est pas bon pour la planète
guerlet encore un type est ce que la
recharge sans fil est plus avantageuse
que la recharge avec chargeur non c'est
plus pratique parce que tu le prends tu
le pote tu m'aides pas néanmoins tu
auras pas la même vitesse de charges ça
vous changera beaucoup plus vite si tu
as un bloc de charge rapide avec le
chargeur qu'avec de la recharge sans fil
en tout cas pour l'instant 2010 quel est
le meilleur smartphone entre l'iphone
dit c'est l'iphone 10 r je dirais que
l'iphone 10r sera plus puissant parce
que tu vas voir ou puces plus
performantes mais je dirais que
l'expérience globale va être plus
intéressante avec l'iphone 10 salue
monsieur brochet arte vidéo depuis un an
je te regarde dans le rer d en partant
au boulot ou cool merci bien dis moi je
viens d'acquérir
ya deux mois le au nord 8 6 928 giga est
ce qu'il fait là faire encore où est ce
que je dois changer de smartphone
aujourd'hui
non on garde le garde le loria l'encoche
effectivement retard par rapport aux 9 x
et bien sûr le 9 x vous n'avez pas
d'encoches donc voilà on peut dire ah
c'est un peu dommage
la petite voix comme ça non il marche
encore très bien le 8 x tu peux le
garder je pense que ça vaut le coup que
penses tu de l'écosystème android
je me pose pas la question de
l'écosystème android c'est plus des
écosystèmes de marque éco système google
avec le nest avec tout ce que vous y
retrouver ce côté là ça va être les
écosystèmes au nord jusque au système
shinobi avec l'écosystème web sont des
écosystèmes de marque plus que les
écosystèmes des os comme android
à quoi peut servir une monde connecté
elle déjà avoir leur primauté ensuite
avoir des notifications à pouvoir
répondre à des appels avec certainement
de connecter à avoir des données de
santé si tu fais du sport tas pour moi
la mieux connectée c'est une extension
du smartphone comment fait-on pour te
poser des questions pour la faq la
tienne le fait reste elle en fait si
vous voulez poser des questions pour
l'évacuer voulait marquer en bas en
commentaire je regarderai sous cette faq
là les questions et j'y répondrai dans
la prochaine afin qu est ce que ça vaut
le coup d'acheter un iphone sans avoir
un écosystème d'apple oui bien sûr sans
aucun problème pour moi j'ai eu
longtemps un iphone sans avoir toi
l'écosystème apple les iphone marche
très bien et que tu penses que les
prochains iphone auront des encoches je
pense qu'on va retrouver encore des
encoches chez apple pendant 7 à 1 en
deux ans un moment il va falloir changer
aujourd'hui apple c'est moins
d'entreprises qui montre les novations
qui apporte l'innovation c'est quelqu'un
pendant longtemps
aujourd'hui c'est plus une entreprise
qui implante une innovation aux
smartphones lorsqu'elle a été éprouvée
vue marche de tous les côtés on pourrait
penser qu'elle a un train de retard en
fait c'est juste que quand il intègre et
quelque chose dans leurs produits ils
veulent vraiment que ce soit à 100% ou
autre ça marche parfaitement bien tout
soit vraiment hyper maîtrisé il faut
savoir que apple quand même un
écosystème qui marche très très très
bien du point de vue matériel qui marche
très très très bien du point de vue
logiciel
le système marche parfaitement bien
extrêmement maîtrisé je pourrais
regretter je le regrette un contre ou
encore sept grandes causes sont 2017 je
vous ai déjà dit dans mon test des
iphones 11 de cette année on va la
garder
je pense encore un petit moment mais à
terme elle finira par disparaître penses
tu que vous ne plus sortir à un jour un
format compact style pixel 3s disent peu
j'aime bien cette marque mais suis
plutôt sur leur marque en fait aurélien
ce qu'il ya c'est que wang plus or très
peu de smartphones et s'inscrit dans les
tendances très tendance en ce moment
sont plutôt les grands écrans donc en
plus faux pas des smartphones avec des
grands écrans cette année ils ont déjà
changé en proposant 2
mark von un modèle normal et aborder le
professionnel ça n'aurait pas de sens
dans l'immédiat mais peut-être à
l'avenir ça ça compliquait les armées
mais pas avant plusieurs années à mon
ami mais on perdra un peu l'adn de la
marque
ça me paraît très surprenant est dommage
pourquoi y at-il de sony bashing en fait
y'a pas de se l'imaginer ça dépend ce
que tu te prends chez sony les caméras
sont vraiment top
les télés sont vraiment top les casques
sont vraiment top sony est vraiment top
dont beaucoup de mails il ya un domaine
sans cali sont en retard qu'ils arrivent
pas ils ont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de mal eh bien ce sont les smartphones
alors ils essayent propose des choses
qui sont différentes trouver son valeurs
qui sont différentes
xperia one est intéressant xperia ça que
je vous dirais désir que jo c'est un
petit peu ça paye aujourd'hui je pense
que sony un petit peu de mal à se
trouver sur le smartphone ou mais il
faut dire aussi que le marché est
extrêmement compliqué
quel est le meilleur opérateur d'espagne
et naulleau c'est salut c'est aziz
depuis bénin salut azizia précités vidéo
ayant une note 9 vaut-il la peine
vraiment de passer aux notes 10 plus de
samsung
non non non avec le nôtre 9 pas déjà la
caméra à ouverture variable qui marche
très bien
effectivement les choses en plus avec
une hotte dise plus mais le lot 9 reste
très actuel aide-moi choisir samsung
iphone ou en plus ça dépend de
l'écosystème c'est surtout ça en fait la
différence c'est l'écosystème ça dépend
de l'écosystème ça dépend de l'ouest
c'est pas tant le produit parce que
toutes les marques que tu me cites ont
des très bons produits ça dépend quel
produit tu veux parce que c'est samsung
tu vas voir l'entrée de gamme tu vas
voir le très haut de gamme par vraiment
les deux apple c'est un peu différent
chez one plus également ça dépend
vraiment ce que tu veux donc désolé
manuel qui plutôt à un os ou android
plutôt les deux pointus faire une vidéo
sur l'eau moreno deux aides
oui mais si quelques jours du temps à
quand la vidéo sur la gopro 360 wii aux
pros max elle arrive très bientôt s'il
bat supportant les téléphone de lg le lg
a du mal au niveau des smartphones qu'il
continue à lancer des smartphones mais
pas en france je dirais que lg c'est un
petit peu comme sony ils ont plus un bon
produit de tous les côtés mais au niveau
du smartphone c'est un peu difficile
tu va tester les odeurs ne fixe les là
que penses tu de wen wei wang wei est
très bon très pratique très fonctionnel
j'aime beaucoup pourquoi ne faites vous
pas de vidéo sur la marque blackberry
alors mon retour je pourrais j'aimerais
beaucoup mais pour l'instant je ne suis
pas en lien avec blackberry d'ailleurs
bédard et si vous regardez cette vidéo
bien qu'on travaille ensemble moi j'ai
les tubes premium donc je n'ai plus de
pub et du coup est ce que tu gagnes
quand même de l'argent
oui il ya une partie
de l'argent qui est reversée aux
créateurs google home ou amazon alexa ça
dépend de ton écosystèmes moi j'utilise
google phone parce que j'ai tout
l'écosystème google et que j'aime bien
l'écosystème google attend d elle en
train de parler alexa derrière ce que
j'aime bien chez google en fait c'est
que je peut lier mon google photo mon
agenda
je vais avoir tous mes rendez vous de la
journée je vais un match tweet je peux
tout d'abord ça c'est très pratique donc
qui fait la force pour moi aujourd'hui
google c'est l'écosystème alex adam je
suis très bien là beaucoup d'affaires
avec penses tu que les nombreuses
petites marques chinoises ont un avenir
à long terme je pense que c'est
compliqué le marché bouge beaucoup
évolué énormément déjà depuis deux ans
il a énormément évolué et il a continué
à évoluer dans les années à venir c'est
difficile de se projeter pour savoir si
elles ont un avenir je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de consommateurs qui va y avoir
une multiplicité des offres des
appareils dont potentiellement oui après
ça dépend des marchés peut-être pas
partout je voudrais savoir si les
smartphones seront compatibles pour la
5g pour 2020 merci non si tu n'as pas un
smartphone qui est 5g compatibles dès
maintenant il ne sera pas compatible en
5 g sur les réseaux français ça il faut
vraiment faire garde parce qu'en fait
c'est une question de mode m
il faut que le modem à l'intérieur de
votre smartphone soit 5 g compatible
s'il ne l'est pas c'est pas la bague
aujourd'hui les produits sont vendus en
france si vous êtes en france eh bien
ils ne sont pas 5 g compatible qu il
fallait que vous puissiez acheter un
produit 5 g compatibles ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
néanmoins il ya des produits qui vont
sortir qui seront compatibles 3g donc si
la question se pose aujourd'hui de
changer votre smartphone et que vous
envisagez pour de l'abonnement 5j année
prochaine
attendez un petit peu de voir ce qui va
arriver parce que il faudra pour avoir
la 5g racheter un smartphone et ça
risque de coûter un petit peu cher
pourquoi yat-il encore beaucoup de
vidéos dans l'ancien studio tout
simplement parce que là le studio pour
les coups de fil c'est mon studio à
paris quand vous me voyez dans l'ancien
studio c'est là où j'habite à à clermont
ferrand
comme dit on des vidéos tous les jours
au genre là où vivent ma famille est
bien pour tourner je me mets dans
l'ancien studio c'est quand même
beaucoup plus pratique que me retrouver
dans la rue moi qui me lance sur youtube
j'aimerais savoir comment tu fais pour
recevoir des téléphones pour les tests
et bien je travaillais avec des agences
de
relations presse je travaille aussi
directement avec des marques si tu veux
commencer à travailler que des agences
ce que je te conseille c'est d'aller sur
les sites tu vas dans pressante bas que
terre les contacts et tu leur équipe
est-ce que la gabegie de samsung est
mort oui m'orienter la gamme pas
maintenant qu'ils arrivent lagarde
s'était milieu de gamme maintenance et
milieu de gamme entrée de gamme les lots
nos cieux grande île depuis le cameroun
salut au cameroun d'ailleurs bonjour à
tout le monde du secam hong kong qui me
regardent en afrique donc ces bâches
mots coulent bonjour à tous merci droit
du gros bisous un grand fan de taishan
chine à canton premier voyage en afrique
centrale
je suis déjà allé gilles en afrique
centrale je suis allé au nigeria j'y ai
passé plus d'un mois c'est en 2003
d'ailleurs j'ai fait une vidéo pour vous
raconter
elle s'étend mais première vidéo vous
cherchez sur ma chaîne vous regardez
vous tapez nigeria devait tomber dessus
c'est une sacrée expérience pourrait
tester et le huawei may 30 pro
probablement prochainement probablement
comment as-tu crée ton site internet
wordpress monsieur heureux je vous écris
depuis le gabon est un jeu flash grave
sur le au nord 20 provoquer mais je
voudrais savoir combien de temps doit
j'attende pour que le prix baisse un peu
c'est compliqué matt de répondre là
dessus je te dirai attendre lac friday
fin novembre et je pense que l'on va
voir des propositions très intéressantes
peux tu nous parler un peu de ton mac
modèle pourquoi un mac et pourquoi pas
windows 10 alors c'est très facile aux
romains quand j'ai commencé à faire de
la vidéo j'avais un mac déjà et j'ai
installé final cut pro et je sais monter
que surprise en cup parce que j'ai mes
habitudes je pense qu'il faudrait les
sur première pour pouvoir changer entre
un mac et un pc sont parait très bien
mais pour l'instant j'ai toutes mes
habitudes là dessus donc c'est pour ça
que je suis sur ma table 6 ou ipad pro
ça dépend ce qu'on veut faire ça dépend
de l'usagé si on veut aller très loin au
niveau professionnel je dirais peut-être
ipad prompt à quand la prochaine afin qu
assez maintenant
penses tu que les smartphones sorti
cette année seront impactés par
l'arrivée de la 5g car je compte acheter
un au nord 20 pro prochainement mais je
me demande ça vaut vraiment color une
fois de plus si tu veux acheter un
smartphone 5g compatible attend les
smartphones de 2020 parce que les
smartphones pour l'instant ne sont pas
compatibles 5g et ça vaut le coup pour
le haut normand proulx j'aimerais savoir
si j'attends le plus cette trop sur
darty car il est à 536 euros fake ou pas
alors raphaël regarde c'est déjà s'est
vendu par darty ou si c'est rendu par la
marketplace est revenu par la
marketplace il faut que tu regardes les
commentaires les avis qui est la
boutique normalement j'imagine que s'ils
sont référencés chez darty ces cas pas
eu trop de problèmes parce que s'il ya
des problèmes' a pu remonter jusqu'à
darty et moi j'imagine quand même qu'il
les supprimer ça me paraîtrait en tout
cas normal mais quand 90
hertz sert à rien aux yeux de voix qu'en
25 images par seconde oui et non en fait
les faits 90' décor tue pas vendu 90 ans
mais l'idée du 4e dire ça apporte de la
fluidité
lorsque vous à l'escroc les besoins des
choses qui sera beaucoup plus fluide et
notamment lorsque vous allez faire du
gaming et bien vous sentir ce qui sera
beaucoup plus fluide ça sera beaucoup
mieux au niveau de l'expérience tu
préfères téléobjectif ou ultra grand
angle
je préfère t l'objectif souvent une bien
meilleure qualité que jutra qu'entendent
même s'il ultra-grand-angle est
intéressant mais définitivement
téléobjectif saluer ce que tu as deux
gros projets si oui lequel j'ai plein du
gros projets j'ai des choses pour 2020
je râle un peu plus loin sur 2021 mais
bon stand by step
je suis donc certain temps déjà mais
qu'est ce que tu fais merci beaucoup
j'ai un iphone si c'est ce qui commence
à prendre de l'âge aimerait donc changer
de téléphone est le one + 7 des pros
m'intéresse beaucoup seul problème c'est
que je n'ai jamais pris de téléphones
android du coup je suis très excité en
constitue alors en fait c'est très
simple bisou de la région salut à tous
les réunionnais c'est très très simple
tu vas voir n'hésite pas il ya tout qui
vachement bien sûr votre plus c'est que
tu as une petite appli qui permet de
switcher de ton iphone ça va tout
importer directement quand on voit de
plus tout ça c'est déjà vachement cool
et puis surtout tu vas est habitué très
rapidement android au début tu vas faire
genre à tanger pas dire père j'y
comprends rien comment ça marche c'est
un peu la loose
et puis l'espace et les semaines et
quant au repreneur dont iphone tu diras
je me souviens plus comment il faut que
je fasse ce comment ça marche ça ne
paraîtra tellement évident dans le monde
plus que tu te souviendras même pas
comment ça marchait sur un os tu verras
pour s'habituer
j'ai eu pendant très longtemps au moins
depuis sept pros et je peux t'assurer
que les produits sont vraiment cool et
surtout par rapport à l'iphone si c'est
ça va tout changer complètement quels
sont les effets de la 5g sur l'homme à
long terme écoute c'est une très bonne
question tu poses là je pense qu on en
reparlera il va falloir j'allais faire
un sujet très important dans le dessus
parce que il ya beaucoup de questions
sont soulevées et une fois de plus ça va
être très compliqué lors les réponses
dans l'immédiat voilà c'est tout pour
cette faq quarante et une minutes bordel
de bordel ça ferait vidéo peut-être la
plus longue de la chaîne je vais côté
plein de choses a cédé à courir tout ça
mais bon il ya beaucoup de choses à
raconter des fois si ce format un peu
trélon vous intéresse est ce que ça vous
intéresse que je réponde à toutes vos
questions comme ça et si c'est le cas
presque toutes vos questions en bas dans
la prochaine afin qu on peut parler de
smartphones mais on peut aussi parler de
la chaîne parler de ce que vous voulez
de tout ce qui vous fera plaisir à les y
fait plaisir sur ce je vous embrasse
j'ai une petite soirée
je vais pas là postés dans la vidéo
parce qu'elle est déjà très très très
longue
je vais mettre sur instagram story si
vous voulez tout savoir rejoignez-moi
sur instagram monsieur underscore
heureux comme ça vous serez tous font
des bisous à bientôt donc